alors un fantôme c'est un mort et dans
l'imagination il revient non ah oui et
oui mais dans l'imagination n'est pas là
en fait alors oh ça se discute parce que
moi je reviens du Bénin et là-bas si par
exemple vous priez un bon Dieu le bon
Dieu vous allez le voir la nuit dans vos
rêves et il va vous apporter par exemple
si vous êtes fiancé un bébé très bien
le mauvais Dieu
celui-là il va vous apporter que des
malheurs mais vous savez c'est pas des
blagues bien sûr moi je vois quand
j'avais 6 ans j'ai eu la douleur de
perdre mon papa dans un accident de
voiture et il m'arrivait après de rêver
à lui si j'avais pas une bonne note je
me disais c'est papa qui descend du ciel
pour m'engueuler j'ai des choses qui
existent et puis vous aviez regardé
l'avion fantôme des États-Unis qui a tué
je sais pas combien de milliers de
personnes au Vietnam et puis il y avait
le le fantôme de Wagner qui a été écrit
à Meudon à côté c'était la mère
déchaînée le fantôme de l'esprit mauvais
et en Angleterre tenez vous bien en
anglais vous avez par exemple polygone
chez le saint fantôme c'est le
saint-esprits
en quelque sorte le Saint-Esprit qui est
un fantôme c'est ça alors c'est un peu
bizarre quand même mais je pense que les
fantômes en France il y en a pas on
croit pas beaucoup
25%2 parce que le fantôme il est lié à
la déjà vu
mais alors vous savez si vous allez en
Écosse le Loch Ness là le monstre du
Loch Ness il paraît que certains l'ont
vu mais on n'est jamais allés vérifier
ça va de ça en fait le fantôme il peut
vous rendre l'espérance si c'est un bon
fantôme et peut vous intéresse ici un
mauvais alors ça dépend des pays ça
dépend des religions mais c'est vrai
qu'en Afrique des fantômes vous en avez
pas mal mais vous vous y croyez alors je
ne crois pas aux fantômes mais je dis
que
ce n'est pas un possible c'est à dire je
pense que ça peut faire du bien à ceux
qui sont en grande difficulté c'est
pendant les guerres j'espère qu'on aura
pas une troisième guerre mondiale mais
on en est pas sûr et malheureusement sur
de rien la famille de ma mère elle vient
du Chemin des Dames il y a eu 200 000
morts en 14-18 mais il y en a qui
croyaient au fantômes c'est à dire il
rêvait toute la nuit que la deuxième
guerre mondiale elle est arrivée elle
est arrivée alors grâce à Hitler ma mère
a pu faire des études
d'infirmières parce que elle elle savait
que ça allait revenir à la guerre et son
père a dit bon je t'autorise à faire des
études d'infirmière mais c'est pour
soigner nos soldats sur les fantômes
mais il y avait on rêvé au Chemin des
Dames là dans l'Ain il y a eu 200 000
morts je vous dis on rêvait et sur les
fantômes on est comment
c'est-à-dire elle est moche avec les
casques mais il y en a qui rêvaient au
bon fantôme c'était les Américains
les fantômes c'est dans nos rêves oui
mais pas seulement c'est pas seulement
dans nos rêves on dit ça ça va se
produire il y a des événements
malheureux ou heureux et effectivement
on y pense on y rêve on peut rêver au
bonheur aussi et ça se produit mais
c'est pas toujours le cas de la même
façon dans tous les pays la planète je
vous dis dans les religions
traditionnelles africaines il y a
beaucoup plus de fantômes ou mauvais
comme en France moi je trouve que la
pratique religieuse diminue et je pense
que
c'est normal qu'il y ait seulement un
cas alors
par rapport aux symptômes
qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire je voulais
sur les fonds
il y a les maisons hantées ça ça existe
moi j'ai été dans des maisons qui
étaient hantées et d'ailleurs quand on
loue pour donner un conseil aux gens
quand on loue achète une maison toujours
passer une nuit ou deux dans la maison
par la visite en journée parce que si la
maison est hantée les fantômes arrivent
la nuit ça c'est un bon conseil
une très importante pendant la dernière
guerre
du côté de Paimpol entre Paimpol et
Saint-Brieuc c'était la maison hantée et
manque de chance les Allemands se sont
installés là avec la Gestapo finalement
on peut dire que il y a eu entre le réel
et le fantasme ou le fantôme un lien
mais aujourd'hui il y a des maisons
que vous y croyez il va nous sortir la
guerre de Cent Ans
mais je vous ne dirai pas je nique
je pense que le fantôme ça peut être
l'espérance ça peut être le désespoir
maintenant je vais vous raconter un truc
incroyable
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était deuxième guerre mondiale
vous savez qu'on est en 2020
le truc le plus incroyable vous allez
dire que je raconte des bêtises c'est
que ok il y a quelques semaines je monte
à la basilique du sacré-cœur et je vois
deux gares qui de costaud africain qui
qui fouille les sacs pour vérifier qu'on
a pas de bombe et il y en a un qui dit à
l'autre oh on va le garder
qui on va le garder et je dis vous vous
êtes de Côte d'Ivoire et vous voulez
garer garder le président Ouattara parce
que vous savez qu'il est musulman et que
jamais les terroristes ne vont le tuer
et il me dit mais comment vous savez ça
je dis je sais pas mais dans mon
imaginaire le fantôme Ouattara il est là
tant que vous l'aurez jamais ils
n'oserons tuer un président musulman
c'était un peu dans mon imaginaire
c'était pas faux mais pas ouf
c'est fou c'est fou c'est fou
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est fou c'est fou oui est-ce que
vous avez d'autres histoires
le premier jour le premier cours il me
lançait un petit avion en papier ensuite
un petit préservatif
il y avait Daniel en cours
[Applaudissements]
ensuite le pire si j'avais la main dans
la poche
autrement que ta poche arrête de te
branler
que ceux qui étaient en première année
ils comprennent rien ils entendent rien
au niveau des fantômes
je pense qu'il est dans l'imaginaire
parce que je dirigé aussi le bureau des
pleurs à savoir ceux qui allaient
redoubler qui avait tout raté dans la
médecine qui me disait je vais me jeter
dans la Seine il attendait un petit peu
et il y avait il y avait de l'imaginaire
il pensait que si on n'était pas médecin
on était mon père est médecin ma
grand-mère était médecin ma sœur aînée
elle est interne et moi je suis une
idiot donc je me jette dans la chaîne
et ils avaient fait de la médecine le
fantasme de du meilleur si je suis pas
médecin je suis foutu
hier je suis allé retourné
non
mais les filles sont super savoir ce
qu'elles sont sympas
et il faut savoir que en médecine ce
sont les étudiants qui disent le
président de l'étudiant en médecine
c'est lui le patron
et sur les fantômes alors les fantômes
c'est pas évident parce que si
vous vous peut dire que dans certains
cas
le fantôme chez le doyen il sert à rien
les fantômes mais on est alors
moi je pense que les fantômes vous en
avez partout mais les fantômes les plus
importants et les moins connus c'est
dans les États-Unis notamment avant
l'arrivée
de l'indépendance il y en a beaucoup
ils croyait que on pouvait faire agir le
ciel il y avait les sorcières de Salem
et une pensée que les sorcières étaient
là orchidée de sorcières sont là c'est
des fantômes mais mais ils en ont ils en
ont tué je sais pas combien parce que
j'étais des sorcières et finalement on
s'est aperçu que c'était une bêtise
voilà voilà alors
c'est pas mal
rassurez-vous il y a des fantômes qui
font du bien donc au dos donc en fait
vous n'avez jamais vu de fantôme
mais je ne dis pas que les fantômes
n'existent d'accord très bien et oui et
puis qui dit fantôme
[Rires]
et puis je vous ai déjà voilà qui dit
fantôme donc maison hantée et exorcisme
aussi
[Applaudissements]
il a dit je suis exorcés et c'est à
peine de 70 ans on l'a viré là paroisse
on l'a mis dans une autre paroisse et
c'est à peine une femme de 90 ans
je suis exorcé j'amène le bon Dieu mais
le curé est allé voir tout de suite la
police la justice etc
les gens qui croient au surnaturels
n'importe comment ça peut être
extrêmement dangereux n'oublions pas que
Hitler a été un excellent enfant de cœur
et oui c'est vrai et Staline un très bon
séminariste tous les deux ils ont tué
sais pas combien de millions de
personnes
dès qu'on vous cause surnaturels il peut
y avoir le meilleur et il peut l'avoir
le pire surtout pas j'ai été très ami
avec des Justes parmi les nations qui
ont sauvé des centaines de juifs ils
étaient très religieux des évêques très
mais ils peuvent aussi
anthonya je voulais poser une dernière
question Anthony oui je voulais savoir
si vous étiez payé pour vos recherches
alors malheureusement
je vais vous dire très franchement je ne
suis pas payé du tout voilà mais mais ça
me fait tellement plaisir que c'est
comme ça bravo donc
[Applaudissements]